bonjour et merci d'être avec nous on
dirait que sur rt france alors vous êtes
à bangui que pouvez-vous nous dire sur
l'art journée de vote ni hier comment
s'est-elle déroulée
je vous remercie les sens je suis à
bangui hier j'ai voté à bangui les
saprophytes était vraiment mobilisés
pour aller effectuer leur devoir civique
si les choses dans la ville de banlieue
être amoureux ça c'est dépassé par
contre dans l'arrière-pays c'était une
catastrophe en sélection et eric
attention il faut avoir le courage
d'utiliser le terme approprié
le plan de sécurisation et de
stabilisation des élections qui nous ont
été vendus depuis deux mois n'a pas
fonctionné je vais vous donner un
exemple damas propres circonscriptions
électorales parce que je suis aux
ti-cats now de la ville que ce sont des
élections groupées
la population a bravé les menaces elle a
voté jusqu'à midi et à 12h30 n'est qu'un
élément de vous armer son gré tout
simplement être que l'énergie solaire et
les urnes et non et les nombreux l'aide
à la soirée est la base de la minustah
se trouve à moins de 100 km de là à
carlo 15 grandes villes de plus de 30
mille électeurs et les élections se sont
déroulées jusqu'à la fin a achevé et on
regarde vraiment toi personne sur le
mammouth et sont venus tirer et tous
leurs n'a disparu ils ont saccagé et
détruit réservé de l'asie mais menacent
et dans tout l'est du pays il ya
plusieurs grandes villes qui n'ont pas
voté avant d'arriver au centre du pays
il a commencé à voter qu'en début
d'après-midi et uniquement sur ses
membres de sa direction ne sont pas
incluses vivre il ne faut pas que là on
passe d'un abus de la neige et au
verglas propagande par rapport à quelque
chose qui ne s'est jamais réalisé de
cette manière la halle centrale et les
bulgares mais partout entre sûr qu'il
sera fait mais n'a fait bleus intervient
aussi très nouveauté alors qu'on on nous
a toujours dit qu'il y avait un plan de
ce qui vous assure mise en place et
c'est un échec total et il faut avoir
l'honnêteté intellectuelle de leur
aurait donc selon vous les conditions
sécuritaires n'étaient pas réunies pour
organiser ce scrutin
il aurait dû
de fallu leur portée j'avais demandé à
aux demandes vont partir et beaucoup
d'autres par sa plastique est conscient
de la nécessité d'aller aux élections on
demandait juste un record de deux
semaines tant que les forces
internationales qui sont venus à pied
l'avenue sky réforme véritable aubaine
pour sécuriser un maximum de villes pour
que au moins la majorité de ses anciens
votre derrière ça n'était pas le cas
vous l'avez cité voire davantage au
portel - c'est la première ville du pays
et à y voir personne n'a voté dans toute
l'afrique tueur de l'année les membres
dans toute la préfecture de l'oise dans
toute l' dans toute une partie de
l'empennage sauf une seule ville par la
force comique et de l'ambré loin pdc un
bassin plus peuplée que ben ali est
arrivé pas voter comment vont faire
parler d'elle crudités et de crédibilité
de ce processus électoral
il y ait un discours qui est tenu à
l'endroit de la communauté internet de
l'autre les intervenants qui est
complètement faux par rapport à ce qui
se passe réellement sur le terrain
c'est une escroquerie politique c'est de
les élections der wiel escroquerie
politique une violation flagrante des
droits et des libertés des santa fe et
surtout le droit de choisir leurs
dirigeants
et pourtant depuis des mois la sonnette
d'alarmé était sonné et personne n'a
voulu entendre et comme d'habitude on va
se mettre d'accord pour avaliser calme
ce qui est inacceptable et c'est trois
heures par jour devant une
méconnaissance fbi
je veux dire pour ne pas être
actuellement le territoire centrafricain
est occupé de quelle manière par les
groupes armés y est loi nome les
gouvernés sont allés frapper à carnot
carlos est à plus de 400 km de bangui
dans le sud ouest du pays et à ghazi a
gagné c'est à l'issue de la joute et
appuie le 6 sacrés du mariage ils ont
frappé partout et idéaux qu'ils ont
frappé partout et libre en ya eu des
réactions comme si c'est un seul
affrontement entre les toupins les
légumes et les mandats d'arrêt ou une
seule vocation dissuasive des forces
internationales pour les empêcher de
faire ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont duré
mesure de partout ils ont ils ont ce
qu'ils ont tiré la population c'est vous
seul se sauver par tous
il ya vraiment deux villes ont voté sur
la vingtaine de villes que contre la
révolution africaine
comment on peut prendre au sérieux cette
démarche je pense que c'est rituel qui a
été convenu mais ce n'est pas des
élections c'est les pelles d'occasions
ils s appellent dans leur majorité
rejoignent leurs députés et l'herbe leur
part que va m'apporter ce que tu
électorale il n'ya pas eu d'élection
[Musique]
monsieur ziguélé
très rapidement je répète vous êtes
candidat à cette élection présidentielle
en centrafrique
beaucoup de défis pour celui qui prendra
la tête du pays
sécurité et économie les deux vont de
pair
il ya beaucoup donné déniaient que
pourtant tout aurait pu se résoudre
efficacement et autres revenus pour
connaît la musique de caisse populaire
et est ce qu on peut qualifier cette
élection des élections qui puisse
conférer une légitimité populaire où la
légitimité à partir et que une grande
fraction du peuple que j'active à pied
de 75 ans n'a pas pu goûter la question
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas une
escroquerie politique monsieur ziguélé
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je répète que vous êtes ancien
premier ministre centrafricain est
candidat à cette présidentielle matthiew